Let's go next to our caller from the eight
five, six area code.
Who's calling today from eight five six.
Hi David.
I'm Erin from New Jersey and I thank you for
taking my call.
My pleasure.
I wanted to follow up on, I guess the theme
of last week's call, which was this kind of
division among the list.
Now we agree that we need to really stop all
the infighting among the Democratic Party.
But my question is where did that start?
Because to be honest with you, I'm a kind
of a diehard Joe Biden Fan.
Like if Bernie like take the nomination, I
mean like that's great because you're like,
I'm not knowing that he has a good chance
of winning against Trump, but like I'm going
to be looking for him to reach out to like
it's affected Hillary Clinton voters and like
Joe Biden fans like myself and like kind of
start that process.
If Joe Biden won the nomination, would you
be likewise looking to him to reach out to
people who say, I'm way more progressive than
Joe Biden and I don't know why I should vote
for him.
Like would you likewise expect that of Biden?
Okay.
Absolutely.
Okay, good.
So we want to be consistent on that now.
What makes you a die hard Joe Biden fan?
And what's interesting to me about that is
just that Joe Biden, it's hard for me to imagine
feeling so strongly about Joe Biden because
he's just very, very centered.
So it's like a, it's hard for me to get motivated
around centrism so like what makes you such
a diehard Biden guy?
Yeah,
well I feel like they're like, there's this
connection between Bernie and Trump.
Okay.
And that like find them Bernie or are Trump's
in that they have this characteristic, they
have this personality and it just makes you
want to like them.
Like that's a lot.
Well, a lot of white people like Trump, like,
and that's why I kind of liked them too, even
though I voted for Hillary of course.
But I was like, I w I w I find entertaining
and I find Joe Biden entertaining.
Okay.
But hold on a second.
You sound like you, I'm just trying to sort
of untangle all this.
You, you liked Trump in the same way that
you like Bernie and Biden.
Um, and not in the same way that I like Bernie.
I think Bernie is better on policy, but I
know that people are attached to Bernie in
that way.
Uh Huh.
Okay.
Um, but yeah, I think that Joe Biden, you
liked Trump but you voted Hillary and do you
like Bernie?
But you're a Biden supporter and is, what
about on policy?
Like what Biden policies do you like?
Well that's the thing.
It's not really about policy for me, even
though I do appreciate good policies, but
what's more important to me is like just being
an entertaining person.
So for you, entertainment is an important
thing in terms of who you want to be.
The president of the United States.
Yeah, just being a likable person, I feel
like that's incredibly important.
Like she'll buy is the line of Malarkey.
I think that plays a really big, at least
for me.
Where are you on health care policy?
What health care policy would you like?
Oh, well I'm a bit of a moderate.
I think that I'm keeping the ACA would be
great, although if you want to do more than
that, that's fine.
But it's all about personality with me.
Wow.
And I want to just clarify.
I don't really, I don't like Trump, but Trump
entertains me.
I hate his policies.
I hate the guy, but yeah.
Yup.
Erin.
I'm worried about tree from what you're, what
you're telling me is really concerning to
me.
I'm not going to lie.
So just to, um, get back to the question though.
Like does the healing start with the candidate
or with the voters?
I think it's both.
I think it's both simultaneous.
So you gotta we, we need, we need disagreement
within the Democratic primary.
That is not the type of disagreement that
then ends up helping Trump later on.
It's a gray area.
So I know that there were people emailing
me about this.
David, how can you on the same team at the
same time say that the left has to be careful
about infighting but criticize Democratic
candidates?
Aren't you doing the thing?
I think you got to find a balance and we need
to say all of these people would be better
than Trump during the primary.
Let's fight out.
Let's fight it out for the candidate whose
policy matches ours.
But then when it gets to the general election,
we've got to do the right thing.
Um, Aaron, I'm going to let you go.
I'm, I'm quite concerned about how important
the entertainment factor is to you and I worry
that it does not bode well for the country,
but I really appreciate you sharing your thoughts.
All right, very good.
I'm going to take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up.
We will go back to the phones right after
this.
You don't hang up.
If you're holding